the president of Harvard University has
fallen and it marks a fascinating
development for the higher education
Frontier of the culture
War the beginning of the end for
president claudian gay started on
October the 7th 2023 when Hamas launched
a terrorist attack on Israel killing
more than 1200
people with blood still wet on Israeli
soil the Harvard undergraduate Palestine
solidarity committee authored a
statement co-signed by 33 other Harvard
student groups stating we the
undersigned student organizations hold
the Israeli regime entirely responsible
for all unfolding violence a fierce
media backlash ensued as pro-israel and
pro Palestinian demonstrations erupted
on campuses around the world from the
river to the sea from The River To The
Sea on November 29th a title 9
investigation was launched by the US
Department of Education into
anti-Semitism and islamophobia on
campuses if you few days later Claud and
gay was pulled in front of the US
Congress with two other Elite College
presidents Sally cornbluth of MIT and
Elizabeth McGill from upen it didn't go
well does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context
further Fury exploded on social media
and high-profile Jewish donors began to
pull their funding and demand
resignations it should not be hard to
condemn genocide s ing injured prey
conservative activists began to Circle
Claud in gay they dug up old accusations
of plagiarism and started trolling
through her academic work in response
left leaning mainstream media outlets
and the Harvard Corporation took up
defensive positions around gay in this
tumultuous and difficult time we
unanimously stand in support of
President gay said Harvard's board in a
statement on December 12th with regard
to president Gay's academic writings the
university became aware in late October
of allegations regarding three articles
the fellows promptly initiated an
independent review which revealed a few
instances of inadequate citation while
analysis found no violation of Harvard's
standards for research misconduct the
following week a conservative media
Outlet called the Washington Free Beacon
submitted an anonymous complaint to
Harvard's Integrity office with evidence
of 40 instances of
plagiarism we launched the Claud and gay
plagiarism story from the right the next
step is to smuggle it into the medeor
apparatus of the left legitimizing the
narrative to Center left actors who have
the power to topple her then squeeze
tweeted conservative activist
Christopher rufo as promised they wore
left-leaning media organizations down by
creating a lot of interest in the story
and circulating a preponderance of
evidence of gays plagiarism until
finally the entire mainstream media
machine began to tilt against
gay on the 2nd of January 2024 claudian
gay resigned as president of Harvard
University as it is with every major
event within the culture War the
discourse is now spinning off in every
conceivable Direction but what I'm
trying to do here is to cut through the
noise and draw your attention into the
core of this story and that's that
claudi and gay was purposefully targeted
by conservative activists who knew
exactly what they were doing and why
they were doing it and the reason for
this is that although she might be a
mediocre academic she's a rbrand level
ideological activist and for years she's
been aggressively expanding Harvard's
diversity equity and inclusion
bureaucracy what's wrong with that you
might be asking isn't Dei about
inclusive spaces and affirmative action
if you're still asking those kinds of
questions you need to catch up and
that's why I'm here we've been
interested in Mike n's work on how Dei
activists have been transforming
universities Across the Western world
since before it when mainstream Elite
classes they all go through the academy
and they learn these things and then
they come out and they produce art they
produce journalism they produce the
templates for how we think and so we
live Downstream from the academy so
whatever happens there it will
eventually happen within the culture
it'll manifest in some sense given the
recent Harvard Scandal is undoubtedly a
sign of things to come we've invited
Mike on the channel to share part one of
his brilliant documentary series called
the reformers it's about an undercover
academic sting operation exposes a dodgy
scholarship that legitimizes woke
ideology and it's utterly insane so
without any further Ado
[Music]
enjoy
where would you like to
begin let's start with Peter and James
okay tell me about them Peter bagoan is
a philosophy professor and James Lindsay
is an author with a background in
mathematics they're part of an
intellectual movement that has begun
pushing back at a problem they see
inside the university
system you know you think ah these
people are studying racism and sexism
okay somebody should be doing that and
good then you start looking at it and
they publish some crazy stuff I mean
crazy stuff then you start looking at
the methods that they're using and and
there's no method it's just a bunch of
opinions people are stringing together
and and and they're pretending to be
social scientists these people have
manufactured their own Corpus of
literature and they publish in these
journals and they use that to credential
themselves to sit at the adult table and
have conversations that influence public
policy University policy what an entire
generation of students will learn
microaggressions are real
microaggressions are real it's hijacked
our institutions everybody's petrified
of calling this out because they're
they're afraid of being called the bigot
or a racist or a homophobe well I'm Not
Afraid only a handful of people know
about this because one leak destroys the
whole thing one single leak and we're
we're
buried our goal is to publish as many
papers as we can that are unbelievably
sophisticated parodies and we're going
to publish these in tier one journals so
we're trying to go right to the source
and say look the the whole Enterprise is
bogus and we're hoping that if we can
get to the source and show that the
scholarship that everything's coming out
of is itself a fraud nobody has to
listen to these people anymore it's hard
to convey to people who are not in this
world what an insane idea this
is I mean literally to
delegitimize an entire body of
scholarship upon which university
architecture is predicated they give
tens of thousands of actual degrees in
this stuff they have professors in this
institutes do do you get that we're
going after all of
[Music]
it it's a very strong scholarship by
liberal human and Marxist Scholars which
pointed out that white identity had been
formed at the expense of black identity
it is essential to note that critical
race theory is originally an American
phenomenon and the evidence that America
was a racially divided Society with
blacks as second class citizens until
very recently is
indisputable however with its recent
descent into post-modern discourse
analysis and conceptions of society is
entirely underlain by systems of white
supremacy operating in mysterious ways
CR iCal race theory has become quite
unhinged it threatens to undo much of
the progress that has been made on
Racial equality using methods which
assume racism to be present in any
interaction between a white person and a
person of racial minority results in
always finding it and further
entrenching the belief in an everpresent
white
supremacy a similar pattern has emerged
within feminism where again everything
is seen in terms of a hidden system of
patriarchy which hides beneath a benign
surface the job of the feminist is to
detect it going through life in order to
direct detect ways in which men are
belittling you is unlikely to lead to
female
empowerment hello love hello Peter and
James recruited a third author to their
academic publishing sting a feminist
historian they refer to as the
Oracle hello to meet you and
you Helen has a remarkable ability when
most people read something or try to
learn something and they're like wow
this is [__] they'll just stop
instantly but not Helen
Helen Helen will do something
extraordinary she will keep learning
about it and keep reading it and keep
dinging down and and it's it's
absolutely remarkable so why do you know
so much about it but you're not of it
well I had to study literary theory for
for several years as part of studying
literature but I I just became
interested in it it's such a
counterintuitive and sort of complicated
on the surface but underneath quite
simple um ideology framework for for
belief and that's what's what's always
interested me I studied religion because
I was interested in how these very
complex systems of thought um that are
internally consistent but need not
actually have any basis in
reality how they can spread and how they
can be used for different purposes and
and build on themselves and grow and
this is something that we're seeing with
postmodernism and um sort of it its
successes within sort of social justice
what what are they building what what is
this thing cuz there's there's Reams and
Reams and reams of scholarship and so
it's upside down world there's Reams and
reams of this stuff what what is it they
are building a new culture and social
they're building a new cultural and
social
reality and the goal is to F that upon
you it is it's it's something like a
cult or like a religion or something
that based in kind of broken social
science it's pretty full
on it's a
truth they're religious [__]
maniacs
[Applause]
all right so this is the foyer got a lot
of China stuff this is my wife's office
and that's kind of Her Sacred place so
don't go in there this is the kitchen
that's Teddy here's the fridge help
yourself recycle recing trash no fat
goes into recycling there's coffee every
morning right there here's where we eat
dinner every night that's the table
those are my my grandparents they fled
the Armenian Massacre we usually have a
lot of Chinese people living here so if
you run into them they don't really
speak English just say hello and wave
and they wave back okay here's TV room
we have Netflix Hulu Amazon you put the
TV on and just put what you want and
it's you can figure it out so my son
isn't living in China now you can have
his
bedroom this is the narrow stairs be
careful this is my my daughter's room
she makes me ring the bell every time I
want to go in in his room in his bed
make yourself at home uh there's his bed
we got from Costco very comfortable or
AA very comfortable um yeah Richard
Baldwin is a retired professor who
donated his identity to the project this
way the team had real academic
credentials to submit their papers with
I was uh bringing um speakers to the
college and so I chose him and I I wrote
him and he agreed to do it and I got him
there and we just bed immediately
because it was like we could tell each
other everything I mean we we trusted
each other for some reason from the the
first time we met it's like we hit it
off we we sensing each other and honesty
uh belief in truth and and uh somehow
like I almost felt like we had met in
another lifetime it almost made me
believe in reincarnation because we
clicked immediately and so even after uh
he left after we had a great time we we
kept in touch and that was three years
ago but we've kept in touch emailing or
or uh texting texting stuff like that
he's clean I'm not I'm not one look at
me and that would be it instantly
torpedo and they would know and it was I
couldn't manufacture a fake name or a
fake identity and so he was perfect and
then I yeah go ahead and then I
defriended him on Facebook and I
eliminated all of our social media
contacts so that no one would connect
us they decided to start off by coming
up with a research paper about social
justice
bodybuilding how about pornography yeah
we could talk about pornography for sure
cuz you go online you can find female
bodybuilding porn I'll take I'll take
your word for it but that so that right
there is a is a hook so now Denise
masino is a former competitor and she
everybody in the bodybuilding world
knows that she's done all that stuff she
tons of of what's your name Denise
masino
masino m a SS say I O I
think oh my holy
[__] oh my gosh W she see the porn video
set see what I'm talking about and she's
got this enormous clip and and enormous
um stuff from all those drugs and it's
like she's
big wow that is
just extraordinary
wow
that's all right we're going to have to
use her in this
somehow oh God we so we let's link fat
studies in here somehow maybe we can
make the
claim that female
bodybuilders should be oh God that's
[__] good female bodybuilders should
be morbidly
obese and there should be instead of um
this
unnatural testosterone or whatever drugs
you know Bine growth hormone or whatever
these people take maybe instead of that
they should be you know Twinkies so to
be Mor galarian and then middle American
women can participate in these body
physique shows to help their with their
self-esteem now that's a paper right
there now that now any rational person
who would they would think that's just
totally like that that's crazy like
that's an absolutely insane idea the
more ridiculous we can we can be the
more attention it'll get in the
media body building is crazy Brazilian
jiu-jitsu practitioners are all
homosexuals and closeted and wanting
engage in BDSM sex but can't it's
crazy it also probably will end up in a
decent Journal which is even
crazier Mike you look
just it's a lot just incredulous and
overwhelmed and it's just total
disbelief it's just hard for me to
believe that any of this is going to
work look I guess you believe based upon
the outcome right that's what you
[Music]
believe